the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of agon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie all right ladies and gentlemen we
have a major new update regarding HBO's
House of the dragon and the Knight of
the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge Knight this
official announcement was made by HBO's
executive during an event today in New
York City they revealed when we will see
their upcoming shows like Euphoria The
Last of Us House of the dragon and so
much more now let's have a look at the
new article so you can see what they
said at the event earlier today the
second season of The Game of Thrones
series will Air in early summer of next
year now House of the Dragon is well
enough along to have a first trailer
which they already screened earlier
today but under the condition that its
contents are not described the
announcement was made by HBO executive
Casey BL Bo during an event in New York
City today he said that the second
season has already wrapped filming and
it's currently in post- production in
addition he revealed that Euphoria
season 3 White Lotus season 3 and HBO
Stephen King series welcome to Dairy
have all been moved back to
2025 now the second season of The Last
of Us will begin production in Spring of
2024 that's assuming they get a
resolution of the actor strike and is
also likely to release in
2025 the Executive also revealed that
HBO's next Game of Thrones series The
Night of the Seven Kingdoms the Hedge
Knight hopes to begin shooting in the
spring while no casting has yet been
announced given the SAG after strike it
seems likely the company has some names
in mind if they're looking to shoot that
soon if you've seen any of my recent
videos then you already know HBO has
started looking for actors for the major
roles of Duncan egg the Hedge Knight is
based on Author George R Martin's
incredibly successful Duncan egg novelas
and they Chronicle the story of dunk the
future Lord commander of the King's
Guard guards are Duncan the tall and egg
the Future King Aon Targaryen as they
wander Westeros having Adventures
roughly 100 years before the events of
the novels HBO's executiv said any other
Game of Thrones shows have yet to be
given a green light however they are
still working on new ideas so it does
sound like the series about Jon Snow is
still up in the air I'm very happy to
hear about House of the Dragon airing on
HBO early this summer as you all know
they've already shortened the season by
a few episodes I was worried we might
not see the second season until much
later now it sounds like we might see
the next season in less than 9 months
not only that but it also seems HBO has
already made a trailer that was shown
during this event in New York City I'm
sure some of you are wondering when they
will release it for us fans to see well
if you know HBO then you know they
usually don't release their official
trailers until right before the new
season airs on the network I'm not
expecting to see a full trailer until
this spring what I do think we will get
very soon are some official first look
images then maybe even a short teaser
trailer within the next few months I'm
also excited to see a new season of The
Last of Us in Euphoria now I know I
don't make videos about those shows but
I do love watching them nonetheless I
thought the first season of The Last of
Us was great and I'm definitely looking
forward to seeing what happens next HBO
also said they hope to start filming the
first season of The Duncan egg series
this spring if that happens then we
should be able to see its first season
during the offseason of House of the
dragon as I've said in other videos that
would be amazing because then we would
not have to wait so long to see a new
season of a Game of Thrones series if
HBO has more than one show airing on
their Network each year now we're going
to have to wait and see if anything else
happens with the Jon Snow show I'm not
sure if we will ever actually see that
show HBO has still never given their own
official announcement about it and
according to this new update it seems
they're still a long way off from giving
it a green light also don't forget they
were in discussions about making a
series and a movie about aegon the
Conqueror if you remember there was a
major announcement about HBO making
something in regards to aegon and his
Sister Wives back in April that was when
variety said a new Game of Thrones
series about aegon targaryen's conquest
of Westeros is being actively discussed
at HBO as the show is in its very early
stages no writer has been hired as of
yet those sources say the search is
underway at HBO is Keen to move forward
and get it into development sources also
say there may be a feature component to
the project HBO and Warner Brothers want
to make a feature film that would then
lead into the series though nothing has
been set in stone the show would tell
the story of how aegon and his Sister
Wives Vena and rainy used their armies
and their three dragons to conquer six
of the Seven Kingdoms on Westeros with
the exception of Dorne in doing so aegon
became the first king of Westeros the
first to sit on the iron throne and the
founder of the Targaryen Dynasty those
events happened roughly 300 years before
the events of Game of Thrones once again
HBO has yet to make their own official
announcement this would be the latest
Westeros Bas series at HBO following the
global success of Game of Thrones HBO
has moved to develop a number of series
set in the world created by George R
Martin the move to expand the Game of
Thrones world and potentially tie in a
film is not surprising as the show
remains as one of the most valuable IPS
in the Warner Brothers Discovery Library
Legacy Media companies have also been
working for some time to build on
interconnected film and TV universes
around their biggest titles and that's
with Disney's Marvel Cinematic Universe
being the biggest example now I think
most of us would agree that HBO could
certainly do something like this with
George R Martin A Song of Ice and Fire
Universe I think there's more than
enough history in lore to make a number
of shows and we already know that's what
they want to do today's new update once
again confirms HBO is working on other
ideas based on georgeo Martin's writing
along with the shows that have already
been given a full series order like
House of the dragon and Duncan egg as
always I will make sure to update you
whenever any new information is made
available make sure you subscribe that
way you're always the first to know
whenever I release a new video there
will always be a lot more heading your
way once again I have to thank all of
you for watching another video I hope
you all have a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye
for
[Music]